you can say listen we don't want to
fight anymore we're so sorry
we're going to play the noble card right
now dude i don't care what you're going
to do you kill my dad i'm going to do
whatever i can to ruin your life
so part of me wants to say david noble
there's other part of me that says
aren't we in too deep to play nice now
i think you know i think with the the uh
picture your your painting
uh is one that is a recipe for
perpetual war forever
that
yes we need to protect ourselves under
any
circumstances we need to have a us
military
it should be focused on protecting u.s
citizens and protecting the borders of
the united states not on
creating an offensive platform for war
that has military bases around the world
and is ready to launch wars on a
moment's notice which is what we have
now
and i think what the the recipe
that you're describing is just gonna
produce more people like that 16 year
old whose father was killed who wanted
uh do
violence against u.s citizens or the
united states i think we need to choose
another path
the last 20 years of war has just
created more people
who would wish to inflict harm on the
united states
both by
killing frequently assassinating
militants but frequently by taking the
lives of
innocent civilians who then have had a
grudge against the united states this
strategy that the united states has been
pursuing
has been completely counterproductive
and has really put us at more risk as
u.s citizens and as a country
and that's what needs to change
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and please
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]